[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec à mes côtés marion
becker bonjour mariant - genre oriane et
cette semaine notre invité est marc
fesneau bonjour vous êtes député de
loir-et-cher vous êtes également le
président du groupe modem à l'assemblée
nationale merci d'être avec nous vers
chez vous et c'est au terme de débats
houleux que l'assemblée a adopté le
projet de loi sur les violences
sexuelles et sexistes l'opposition un
reproche à marlène schiappa un manque
d'ambition sur la protection un des
mineurs de moins de 15 ans devant les
sénateurs elisabeth borne à préciser les
nouveaux contours de la réforme
ferroviaire la sncf ne pourra pas être
privatisée
ce sera désormais inscrit dans la loi au
sénat le gouvernement a une nouvelle
fois rejeté la proposition de loi de
revalorisation des retraites agricoles
il reporte le débat la réforme globale
des retraites en 2020
enfin cette semaine était dédiée à la
niche parlementaire modem à l'assemblée
quatre propositions de loi à la tonalité
sociale ont été présentés sans succès et
on commence cette semaine avec le projet
de loi de lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes qui a agité les
musiques de l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au terme de débats houleux l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi
porté par marlène schiappa par 115 voix
pour et 29 voix contre c'est la
répression des abus sexuels sur mineurs
qui a agité les débats et l'abandon du
par le gouvernement de la création d'une
présomption de non consentement des
mineurs de moins de 15 ans elza mondain
gaba il a cristallisé les tensions à
l'exception du groupe la république en
marche l'article 2 a fait l'unanimité
contre lui il nous regrettons le recul
que représente ce dernier dans certains
points par rapport à vos propositions et
à vos interventions que s'est il donc
passé pour qu'aujourd'hui nous ayons un
article qui ne correspondent en rien à
ce qui était possible il ya quelques
mois le texte prévoit que pour les
mineurs de moins de 15 ans la contrainte
morale ou la surprise sont caractérisés
par l'abus de vulnérabilité de la
victime ne disposant pas du discernement
nécessaires pour consentir à ses actes
on part du principe maintenant que le
juge devra tenir compte c'est écrit dans
le texte de la particulière
vulnérabilité du mineur de 15 ans et du
discernement qui est nécessairement
réduit quand il s'agit d'un mineur mais
des députés de tous bords du modem à la
france insoumise aurait souhaité une
présomption de non consentement selon
eux toute pénétration sur un mineur ont
dessous d'un certain âge devrait être
considéré comme un viol vous laisser la
porte ouverte à la possibilité pour un
juge et pour un très bon avocat de
démontrer qu'il y aurait qu il pourrait
y avoir consentement d'un enfant de 12
11 d'être même dix ans la rédaction du
gouvernement a été adopté dans la
douleur 80 une voie pour 68 voix contre
l'article 1 du projet de loi fait lui
passé de 20 à 30 ans la prescription
pour les crimes sexuels contre les
mineurs une avancée même si certains
demandent l imprescriptibilité le texte
permettent également de mieux
sanctionner le cyber harcèlement et créé
par ailleurs une infraction doute rage
sexiste pour pénaliser le harcèlement de
rue les députés ont débattu pendant plus
de 19 heures
des discussions parfois houleuses vous
devez le voter si vous voulez proposer
les enfants vous devez la beauté avec
nous aux lecteurs petits que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure simplement par
votre attitude par la façon dont vous
braquez le débat par la façon dont vous
ne répondez pas aux uns et aux autres
vous êtes en train de faire en sorte que
ce texte ne soit plus un texte qui soit
à textes unanime
finalement le projet de loi était adopté
115 voix pour 29 contre et 25
abstentions
un marc fesneau vous avez voté ce texte
mais regrettez-vous à l'absence d'un
interdit claire de relations sexuelles
entre un majeur et un mineur de moins de
15 ans oui parce que c'était attendu un
peu qui avait été annoncée par le
gouvernement et ça a été vécue si c'est
autour de cet article 2 que les choses
ont été des monts ont conduit à des
débats un peu difficile et un peu
houleux c'est que nous estimions
conformément à ce qu'avait dit marlène
schiappa escaliers du gouvernement qu'il
fallait inverser la charge de la preuve
d'une certaine façon est de dire par
nature un acte sexuel en dessous de 15
ans on parle pas du viol parce que la
question du viol elle reste dans la loi
il n'y a pas de recul du tout là dessus
puisque même l'imprescriptibilité et
augmenter la prescriptive ilité pardon
est augmentée en revanche il nous
semblait que d'inverser les choses
permettait que ça soit pas à l'enfant de
montrer qu'il était consentant ou pas
qu'on s'entend parce que c'est
évidemment un élément qui est très
sensible et très important pour nous
ceci étant la glisse est quand même dans
cet article de quelque chose qui est de
dire dans le consentement on tient
compte de la vulnérabilité de l'enfant
qui est une avancée et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que ce point-là plus les
autres ont justifié le vote favorable
ces débats curité très passionné voire
passionnel c'était débat très sensible
toujours après il faut toujours à la
fois tenir cette passion parce que c'est
bien que les gens portent les choses
avec ce qui est leur connaissance du
sujet leurs appréhensions de tel ou tel
point d'un texte et en même temps il
faut le faire avec la raison le
gouvernement nous a opposé la question
de la constitutionnalité peut-être de
cet inversement de la charge dix ans on
fait on passe de la présomption
d'innocence à la présomption de
culpabilité at il mal et il risque est
justement cette institutionnalisée
parfois utile de deux doses et de
risquer leur pas toute fin parce que
parfois on fait des lois en sachant
qu'on va au bout
ou contentieux constitutionnel et que le
conseil constitutionnel a retoqué alors
on fait reporter la charge d'une
décision dont on savait par avance
qu'elle ne passerait pas au conseil
constitutionnel ce qui est
intellectuellement est un peu malhonnête
mais là peut-être qu'il fallait pousser
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est exprimé assez
fortement sur l'article 2 on pensait
qu'on pouvait aller plus loin que le
texte qui nous était présentée est à la
hauteur de ce qui avait été espéré ce
qui est dommage c'est que c'est un texte
qui était au démarrage qui aurait dû
trouver les voies d'un consensus
on l'a vu hier sur notre niche on la
trouvait là qu'on censure sur trois des
quatre textes que nous proposions là on
a on a manqué à ce consensus c'est un
peu dommage comment comment vous
l'expliquez est-ce que c'est marlène
scapa qui a braqué le débat comme le
disait olivier faur non non enfin je
crois que tout le monde s'est braqué
dans ce débat mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'on fasse les uns et les autres
attention à nos attitudes je pense que
la journée de mardi était une journée un
peu épidermique et les basses et braquer
tout le monde s'est braqué et la journée
de mercredi a été plus comment dire est
plus apaisée je pense que le ton d'un
débat
on peut avoir des positions radicalement
différente la façon dont on dit les
choses
c'est important parce que d'abord on
doit ça au débat démocratique et en plus
ça permet d'avancer et de faire la loi
passe ou coup de la colère avait de
l'émotion mais sous le coup de la raison
et du jeu ce qui est le droit au sortir
de ce débat est ce que finalement le
l'interdît est renforcée oui parce que
la présomption du domaine nabéré
vulnérabilité de l'enfant est quand même
un élément important pour le juge que le
juge pourra dire peut-être il était
consentant mais je pense qu'il était
vénérable aidant c'est un faux débat je
lançais les associations sur ce sujet
oui c'est un vrai débat c'est un vrai
débat parce qu'on a eu des affaires on
est d'où est partie ce texte alors ça
nous a d'ailleurs nous incite à la
prudence
l'origine des textes il est parti d'une
affaire qui est arrivé dans le val
d'oise et qui avait beaucoup sensibilisé
en particulier une députée chez nous
nathalie et limaces et patrick mignola
aussi lui-même
c'est un débat qui montre cet enfant là
on a considéré qu'il n'y avait pas ni
d'atteinte sexuelle n'était pas une
question de vie avait pas d'atteinte
sexuelle parce que finalement elle était
peut-être consentante
simplement il ya un âge on peut estimer
que quelles que soient les choses qui se
passent
on estime que c'est pas qu'on s'entend
donc je pense que c'est un débat et on y
reviendra probablement parce que c'est
une évolution de la société et des tas
de pays européens qui ont été un peu
plus loin que ce qu'on a fait dans ce
texte
ceci dit à des avancées moi je considère
qu'il ya des avancées si nous votions
contre
la prescriptive ilité reste à 20 ans si
nous votions contre la vulnérabilité
n'étaient pas prises en compte si nous
votions contre nous trash et que sexiste
dans la rue ils n'étaient pas prises en
compte pour ge il faut être rationnel
dans la vie et donc c'est pour ça que il
semble que c'est une avancée même si
c'est pour beaucoup pour un certain
nombre un peu décevant effectivement
aller au sénat cette fois elisabeth
borne à préciser les nouveaux contours
de la réforme ferroviaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et la ministre des transports a confirmé
à l'incessibilité de la sncf
l'entreprise restera bien public et ce
sera inscrit dans la loi
écoute elisabeth bornes le texte qui
vous est présenté prévoit que la sncf
reste une société 100 % publique la loi
empêche de fait toute cession de titres
puisque c'est l'intégralité des capitaux
qui devraient être détenues par l'état
ce qui veut dire que c'est le régime
enfin c'est la formulation la plus
protectrice puisqu'elle ne permet pas
une augmentation de capital par un un
autre que l'état cela étant consciente
de la portée symbolique de la
proposition et que la répétition a des
vertus pédagogiques
je suis favorable à l'inscription du
caractère incessibles du capital dans la
loi il en est de même pour sncf réseau
et sncf mobilité et je rappelle par
ailleurs que le domaine public
ferroviaire est par nature inaliénable
car c'est le bien de tous que l'état
confiera à sncf réseau nous sommes donc
loin d'une privatisation que certains
veulent agitée marc fesneau il était
nécessaire d'inscrire son caractère
incessibles ça n'allait pas de fortes
sommes pour nous ça allait de soi mais
simplement certains nous faisaient le
procès de l'idée que nous avions
derrière la tête d'une privatisation on
confond souvent mise en concurrence et
privatisations ne veut pas non plus
toujours avoir un débat serein sur ce
sujet dans la tête du gouvernement dans
la tête de la majorité n'est pas
question de privatiser la sncf jeudi au
passage qui voudrait racheter la sncf
avec 46 ou 50 milliards de dettes et 3
milliards de déficit annuel faf
si le dire les choses donc faut être
réaliste dans les affaires ceci dit je
pense que c'était que tu des choses qui
étaient qui était demandée par une
partie des syndicats par une partie des
parlementaires la holding était déjà
accessible et maintenant réseau et
mobilité vont devenir accessibles
c'est bien de le mettre dans la loi c-11
vertus comme l'a dit la ministre et dago
gic est une vertu aussi pour rassurer
ceux qui ont toujours besoin par les
textes est rassuré mais je trouve ça
bien et en même temps je trouve cette
manière qu'ont les gens de dire il faut
mettre dans la loi tout parce qu'on ne
fait pas confiance
moi j'ai en tout cas je fais confiance
au gouvernement il n'est pas question de
privatiser la sncf maintenant ça va être
proposé au sénat est débattue au final
c'est très bien
deux syndicats l'unsa et la cfdt ont
obtenu des avancées
certains de leurs amendements seraient
acceptés c'est la clé de la fin de la
grève à la sncf cette possible accord
c'est aux syndicats de le dire j'ai
respect pour les syndicats leur mode
d'action est la volonté qu'ils ont eux
de faire progresser les droits des
salariés
les préserver je pense que c'est la clé
d'un accord avec ceux qui ont envie
vraiment d'une réforme parce qu'en fait
il ya des syndicats qui disent le texte
ne nous convient pas il faut la demande
t il ya la question de la privatisation
putatif si je peux dire il ya d'autres
sujets qui sont le droit de retour pour
les salariés il ya d'odieux il ya des
sujets sur la table qui vont être
examinés c'est à partir du 25 je crois
au sénat est donc là on va avoir des
choses qui ne seront pour moi je pense d
avancer la question de la dette
on a besoin d'un calendrier pour que le
gouvernement rassure aussi parce que la
situation de fragilité de la sncf c'est
la dette et le remboursement de la dette
donc tout ça va dans le bon sens mais
aussi des syndicats disons-le est la
seule chose qu'ils demandent c'est le
retrait du texte
moi je regrette y compris dans les
oppositions que nous avons autour de
nous en tout cas les oppositions qui ont
été en charge de gouverner
tout ça c'est la fin d'un processus qui
a été décidé il ya dix ou quinze ans
l'ouverture à la concurrence ce n'est
pas sous ce gouvernement qu'elle a été
dissipée elle a été décidé par les
gouvernements précédents
il faut mettre en oeuvre il faut il
fallait mettre en situation la sncf
d'être prête à affronter la concurrence
on lui donne du temps puisque la
l'ouverture des lignes d'ailleurs au
sénat je crois qu'un certain nombre de
sénateurs souhaitent aller plus
rapidement dans le processus d'ouverture
à la concurrence nous on essaye de
trouver un calendrier qui permet à la
sncf s'adapter suffisamment pour pouvoir
faire face à l'un des fondateurs qui
sont aussi très sensibles à la question
de l'aménagement du territoire et donc à
cette question des petites lignes est-ce
que des fermetures de petites lignes
sont à craindre
moi je ne crois pas après cette un
dialogue d'abord il ya deux choses sur
les petites lignes
le service le fonctionnement et ça c'est
à voir avec les régions et il ya deux
les réseaux c'est à dire est ce que
l'état continue à mettre sur la table
les moyens de moderniser les réseaux
parce que le propre des petites îles
c'est aussi l'état du réseau des rails
pour dire les choses simplement
en tout cas nous nous serons vigilants
au groupe modem pour faire en sorte que
ces lignes irrigue le territoire je
n'aime pas le mot de petites lignes
parce qu'il a un côté un peu péjoratif
mon l'emploi tous mais c'est digne qui
irrigue le territoire puisse perdurer
après aussi d'état territoire
moi j'ai aidé financièrement maintenant
cci doit il doit aider au travers du
réseau
enfin au travers de la sncf et l'état a
pris des engagements à travers des
contrats de plan après je pense qu'il ya
des tas de territoire ya pas le gars
vous allez dans la creuse avait même pas
de gare à guéret vous avez une guerre à
la souterraine
il ya des tas de gens qui sont à guéret
il faut trouver aussi d'autres solutions
de mobilité on a des moyens maintenant
le covoiturage les bus etc qui
fonctionne beaucoup fonctionné avec les
grèbes et pendant les grèves d'ailleurs
et qui sont des moyens alternatifs pour
des gens qui n'ont pas de solution se
dire lowrie n'est pas la seule solution
de la mobilité on est donc on va voir la
voiture autonome on va avoir un certain
nombre d'outils qui nous permettront de
se mouvoir sur le territoire la question
c'est de chercher à trouver pour tout le
monde
une solution de mobilité quand vous êtes
moi j'étais maire d'une commune de 700
habitants première guerre à 15 km avec
un cadencement modeste on va dire après
ma question pour les habitants de ce
territoire c'est d'aller à la ville
préfecture qui était à blois et saint
cyr a jamais drive donc il faut trouver
des solutions de mobilité
on va passer à un autre sujet marc
fesneau nouvelle bataille cette semaine
entre le sénat et le gouvernement sur la
revalorisation des retraites agricoles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la deuxième fois que cette
proposition de loi communiste était
examinée au sénat elle vise à
revaloriser les retraites agricoles mais
le gouvernement ne le souhaitent pas
avant 2020 et comme lors du premier
examen
il a eu recours au vote bloqué
provoquant la colère d'un hémicycle
largement favorable à ce texte
audrey vieux thèse le rejet est sans
appel pour l'adoption ban deux contre
deux cent cinquante deux symboles de
l'opposition unanime du sénat face au
gouvernement
en ce qui concerne la revalorisation des
retraites agricoles retour en arrière
nous sommes début mars le sénat étudie
une proposition de loi communiste qui
vise à augmenter les retraites agricoles
dès cette année mais le gouvernement
coupe court aux discussions et utilise
le vote bloqué si les sénateurs veulent
voter la loi ils doivent obligatoirement
accepté l'amendement du gouvernement qui
repousse cette révision à 2020 après la
grande réforme des retraites donc
l'hémicycle s'estime museler les
sénateurs sont vent debout et la scène
se reproduit mercredi soir deuxième
examen toujours ce vote bloqué et la
ministre des solidarités qui reçoit une
volée de bois vert il nous semble que
vous ni même par les agriculteurs et
surtout les plus faibles j'ai honte de
penser qu'on puisse simplement ne pas
considérer qu'un agriculteur quel qu'il
soit aujourd'hui n'est pas une retraite
confortable
l'avis de la france l'histoire de la
france elle n'est pas dans les villes
elle a été dans les campagnes les
mépriser comme vous le faites
aujourd'hui m'a menacé un vrai sentiment
de dégoût rien ne parvient à éteindre la
colère des sénateurs pire le ton monte
un peu plus quand la ministre évoque
l'intention du gouvernement de
revaloriser légèrement les pensions des
conjoints d'agriculteurs soulignant un
manque dans la proposition de loi
communiste c'est cet amendement qui a
soulevé cesser cet amendement qui a fait
soulever ce problème plus 27 euros par
mois une aumône condamne les communistes
qui comme bien d'autres sénateurs ont
voté contre la proposition de loi amendé
remettant à plus tard sans savoir
vraiment quand la revalorisation des
retraites agricoles
vous comprenez larcher nos cette
décision du gouvernement est ce
acceptable pour pour ces agriculteurs
mois et coûté j'écoute les
parlementaires
l'air et ps qui s'exprime avec grande
émotion sur le sort des retraités
agricoles
ils ont été en charge de ces questions
là pendant 20 ans ou 25 ans kim a
méprisé pendant 20 ou 25 ans les
retraités agricoles
c'est eux parce que c'est très facile
quand on est dans l'opposition de venir
donner des leçon et des leçons de morale
y compris sur les retraités agricoles
est ce qu'il n'est pas temps aujourd'hui
désistement 4 est certain que le
gouvernement a décidé d'une grande
réforme des retraites à l'horizon 2019
ok pas de reporter aux calendes grecques
tout le monde sait gouvernement attendre
2020 pour revaloriser
nous avons une collègue au groupe
géraldine banier qui fédère et culture
et qui connaît bien ces questions
plusieurs d'entre nous se sont exprimés
pour dire il faut aller vite il faut
qu'on tienne l'engagement du président
de la république simplement il faut le
faire dans le calendrier minimum qui est
celui d'un débat global sur les
retraites le président de la république
a voulu que les régimes puissent
converger que pour un euro cotisé
même si ça sera un peu plus compliqué
que ça pour un euro cotisé on a 1 euros
de pension de retraite que vous gagniez
équivalence des régimes de retraite et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on aura ce débat
pour revaloriser les retraites agricoles
oui c'est injuste personne ne dit le
contraire simplement vous pouvez pas
dire les retraités agricoles en 2019
et puis il ya aussi des conjoints
collaborateurs d'artisans qui sont dans
cette situation là et donc on va égrainé
et il s'est juste ces questions on va
égrener des choses sans regarder la
globalité on reporte pas aux calendes
grecques le gouvernement faire
maintenant pour dire 2020 pourquoi 2020
parce que la réforme elle doit se faire
en 2018 2019 sur les réformes des
retraites et donc première année
d'application à partir de 2020 et nous
tiendrons nous au gouvernement le
discours que je vous tiens là qu'est il
faut revaloriser les retraites agricoles
donc l'engagement sera tenue en tout cas
nous veillerons à ce que l'engagement
soit tout simplement dans le calendrier
qu'elle noté pas le calendrier de ce qui
réinventa calendrier alors que pendant
vingt ans il a bien ça ne va pas creuser
le fossé entre le gouvernement les
retraités
je crois pas je on sait qu'on a un
problème sur la table sur les retraités
agricoles
il faut qu'on avance sur ce sujet là on
le verra au moment des retraites je
pense qu'il faut qu'on trouve un système
qui soit juste pour tout le monde et qui
fasse que les gens soient pas dans des
situations de distorsions comme les
agriculteurs de son un mot sur la
méthode employée par un gouvernement qui
est de nouveau y recourent votre bloqué
vous le déplorez non parce qu'à un
moment quand vous êtes face à vous des
gens alors si jamais agréable d'avoir
recours à des méthodes qui sont les
méthodes un peu contraignante que dont
dispose le gouvernement
simplement il ya un gouvernement ils
décident dé ses orientations avec sa
majorité sur la réforme des retraites
on voit bien aussi vous faut dire les
choses il faut je vois ceux qui
s'offusquent et tout le monde est
d'accord sur la question des retraites
agricoles pour il faut pas s'offusquer
comme ça en sachant très bien que de
toute façon la volonté c'était de faire
passer à toute force et dans le
calendrier qui était leur le texte nous
on avait un autre calendrier vont
accepter aussi ça allait marcher non
poursuit cette fois avec votre niche
parlementaire à ce jeudi à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine à l'assemblée le groupe
modem a donc défendu quatre propositions
de loi dans l'hémicycle dont l'une
entend créer un droit voisin pour les
éditeurs de presse en ligne
elle obligerait les géants de l'internet
les gars femmes à rémunérer les éditeurs
de presse en ligne et les agences de
presse pour l'utilisation de leurs
contenus
écoutez le député patrick mignola et la
réponse de la ministre françoise nessel
on va presser de nouveau en danger son
équilibre économique est déstabilisé par
la diffusion de ces articles sur les
plateformes les moteurs de recherche et
les fournisseurs d'accès ceci les
infomédiaires les gars femmes captent 90
% des investissements publicitaires dans
le digital
nous vous proposons de créer un nouveau
droit économique dit droits voisins pour
permettre aux éditeurs et aux agences de
dialoguer et négocier avec les
infomédiaires une juste rétribution de
leurs investissements il est
inacceptable que les acteurs qui se
contentent de véhicules et les contenus
soient massivement mieux rémunérés que
ceux qui les fabriquent
par ailleurs cette situation n'est pas
viable
je considère que nous devons attendre
avant d'adopter un texte en france le
droit voisin doit se construire d'abord
au niveau européen la france ne peut pas
imposer seuls des règles aux géants
mondiaux du numérique vous acceptez cet
argument c'est d'abord au niveau
européen qu'il faut l'egypte c'est le
principal point de divergence que ce qui
est intéressant dans le débat qui a eu
lieu hier sur ce texte
c'est que la ministe d'abord un s'est
engagé à l'idée qu'il faille il fallait
qu'on puisse créer un droit voisin et
qu'elle le gouvernement français
défendent rsa au niveau européen et deux
qu'il y avait une urgence pour la survie
de la presse qu'il y avait un vrai jeu
là on a une difficulté une divergence
avec le gouvernement c'est que nous
disons commençons pas voter un texte et
ça poussera aussi à ce que le débat au
parlement européen et auprès de la
commission soient plus forts et nous ce
que nous arrivions avec celle
gouvernement dit au contraire il vaut
mieux d'abord que nous que nous
débattions niveau européen n'est ce pas
risqué justement d'engager le débat
européen on connaît les il était jeune
vision en or il est déjà engagée il est
déjà sur la table il ya un certain
nombre de pays qui commence à nous
rejoindre simplement il faut trouver une
majorité pour vendre ce droit voisin et
défendre ce bo3 voisins c'est assez
simple le gouvernement nous dit fin
d'année nous aurons une niche fin
d'année donc on reviendra devant le
gouvernement si dans à la fin de l'année
on se retrouve dans la situation
ce que nous souhaitons c'est ce que tout
le monde souhaite sur les bancs et le
président de la commission des affaires
culturelles aussi de fait tout le monde
s'est exprimé en disant c'est une bonne
idée cette affaire de droits voisins
si c'est voter au parlement ont
transposera dans la dans la suite au
parlement et puis si ça n'est pas voté
la fin d'année ça veut dire qu'il ya un
problème européen qu'à ce moment là il
faut qu'on aille en avant nous on va
passer à la partie politique de cette
émission avec notre partenaire du
figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous accueillons sur ce plateau jean
ferrat c'est bon pour mon bonjour marc
fesneau bonjour on l'a vu avec la
question des niches parlementaires qui
étaient à bord dé vous en avez passé
fait passer plusieurs la question pour
vous c'est de réussir à faire entendre
vos idées tout en réussissant à avoir le
soutien la république en marche un test
important ça va être celui la réforme
constitutionnelle ans qui arrive
vous réclamez plusieurs retouches sur le
texte notamment au niveau de la
proportionnelle est ce que vous avez
vraiment bon espoir de faire modifier de
manière substantielle le texte peut-être
juste une chose sur les nichons avait
hier quatre textes y en a trois qui sont
passés avec la volonté de porter une
fibre sociale sur l'engagement
associatif sur la prestation de handicap
c'est effectivement ce qu'ont les
essayant de porter alors on est dans des
niches faut être modeste ça ne
révolutionne pas les choses mais c'est
des éléments qui sont apportées et des
signaux qui sont envoyées et s'était
fait en pleine entente avec le
gouvernement et la majorité alors après
pour la question sur la réforme
constitutionnelle je ne vais pas oublier
ya pas claqué sur la proportionnelle il
ya une question ou la proportionnelle
pourquoi parce qu'on pense que le seuil
est proposé nous permet pas de
représenter la différents courants
politiques mais il ya d'autres questions
de la question du travail parlementaire
la question de la procédure
parlementaire et la question du pouvoir
du parlement des sénateurs et des
députés
et c'est autour de ça qu'on verra
l'equilibre qui peut se trouver donc oui
je pense que si on veut trouver une
majorité des trois cinquièmes dans la
majorité avec la majorité et avec une
partie de l'opposition parce que c'est
ça l'équilibré qu'il faut trouver
il faudra bien que nous puissions
convergé sur un certain nombre de points
et je pense en particulier aux
procédures parlementaires
la différenciation territoriale qui est
un élément important et donc c'est là
dessus qu'on va aussi se bat tous les
éléments sont sur la table après une
réforme de cette nature là ça a été le
cas en 2008
la réforme du président du quinquennat
de nicolas sarkozy veut trouver des
terrains de compromis est-ce qu'il
n'arrive pas avec des lignes rouges
définitive un mois il faut faire trouver
des composés c'est ce que vous
souhaité que le gouvernement vous tende
la main de façon ostensible par exemple
on vous accorde un poste de rapporteur
sur l'un des textes
il ya là ce serait un peu c'est la
question n'est pas de porter le rapport
au temps de la main n'est pas que la
question du rapport au temps de la main
s'est trouvé un terrain de compromis sur
les sujets que je viens d'abord d après
que la majorité composée de la
république en marché du modèle
travaillent main dans la main au travers
peut-être de cela pour faire en sorte
que nous fassions avancer la réforme
parce que nous sommes porteurs avec
richard ferrand on en a parlé
quand quelques heures de la volonté que
nous aboutissions sur cette réforme si
vous voyez régulièrement venant pas
beaucoup car pour faire en sorte que
nous trouvions entre nous mais pas
seulement entre nous puisqu'il faut
trouver les trois cinquièmes les voies
d'une réforme constitutionnelle
je regrette parfois on verra ce que dit
senna c'est je pense qu'à des sénateurs
qui veulent la réforme constitutionnelle
on verra ce qu'ils sont ce que sont des
débats de posture et la volonté réelle
de faire une réforme constitue alors le
gouvernement et la rupture car on march
fait les un an de pouvoir et françois
bayrou lui fait l'élément à sa manière
en faisant entendre une petite musique
un peu différente dans plusieurs
interviews il a critiqué un manque de
perspectives sociales dans le dans les
réformes du gouvernement est ce que vous
pensez aussi que macro est passé du ni
droite ni gauche à
et droite et droite c'est pas comme
c'est pas sous cet angle là je regarde
les choses le président de la république
a fait une campagne sur le thème libéré
et protéger les premières mesures ont
plutôt été dans le libérer alors le
libérer égale droite pour certains j'ai
du mal à mettre les gens dans des
catégories comme ça on peut aussi penser
qu'il faut protéger ce gouvernement
décide de mettre plus d'un milliard sur
la table pour dédoubler les classes sont
en zone prioritaire je sais pas si c'est
de gauche en tout cas on est plutôt dans
la version du protégé bon simplement il
françois bayrou le dis pas pour fêter
les un an il l'a dit est la rentrée où
il l'a dit elle il a dit à plusieurs
reprises en dix ans il faut qu'on voie
le projet social qu'on a à côté du
projet économique et c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'on défende merci pour ces boues merci
d'avoir été notre invité cette semaine
merci marion merci ariane et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
[Musique]